Hello, everyone.
This is Isaac
Kurtzer, the Department
of Biomedical
Science, Old
Westbury Campus.
And this lecture is
the second of our
three concerning
supraspinal motor systems,
basal ganglia.
We have four session
objectives for this
lecture. First, to identify
what are the nuclei
which comprise the
basal ganglia. There's
10 of them, and they're
going to fall within
certain categories.
Second, what are the
connections amongst
those nuclei that we just
described and the
connection of these nuclei
to structures that
are outside the basal
ganglia? It's not just
encapsulated, it has to
communicate with the
rest of the brain.
Next, we need to describe
a model that helps us
understand what do
these nuclei do in terms
of coordinated
functional behavior and
lastly we need to understand
how all this relates
to dysfunctions of
basal ganglia makes
sense when we see a
certain basal ganglia
dysfunction how we can
track that back to the
nuclei to the neurotransmitters
to the different
functional components
of the basal ganglia
sequences of actions
are important for
navigating our lives
they take a little time
to develop once we've
set them in place they
can proceed pretty much
automatically we call
these habits and
habits is the domain of
basal ganglia so if you
know this song about
the different cranial
nerves on top of olympus
towering top and so on
that song is because
of a habit which is
basal ganglia thank
you very much same
with a songbird same
structure that it learns
its song it's because
of basal ganglia
and then we can have
disordered habits we
can have compulsions and
addictions and this is
because basal ganglia
is not serving us well
so what is basal ganglia
well it's got to be
gray matter because
you say ganglia but it's
within in the cranium
so that doesn't sound
right ganglia aren't
they outside the cns
well it should be
called basal nuclei
but we're just going to
stick with ganglia because
that is the language
that we've inherited
over time so they're
gray matter nuclei
there's 10 of them and
they're connected
amongst each other in a
very interesting way
and they're going to
communicate with the
cerebral cortex to create
these pattern sequences
to create these
habits and there's many
different responsibilities
for the basal ganglia
because you don't
just have habits of
action you have habits
of thought as well sky
high view before we
dive into the details
it will be that cerebral
cortex communicates
with basal ganglia,
which communicates
with thalamus, back to
cerebral cortex. And
this forms a loop all on
one side of the brain.
So the left basal
ganglia output nucleus
would go to a left
thalamic nucleus, which
would target the left
cerebral cortex, and
then back down again.
And then there's a lot
of machinery within
basal ganglia that is
adding something particular
to thalamus so it
takes something from
cerebral cortex and
gives something back a
bit different and so
now we need to examine
what are the nuclei
how do they communicate
with each other and
their transmitters and
this is actually a
pretty long list that's
one of the complexities
of basal ganglia is
that we have 10 nuclei
that are involved and
you'll see them here
right now we can group
the nuclei of the basal
ganglia into three
broad categories there
is the striatum so
the striatum will be
composed of these three
nuclei for the pallatum
that will be composed
of these three nuclei
and And there's
nuclei within the
brainstem and diacephalon,
which include many
nuclei, only a subset are
ones that are linked
to the basal ganglia.
Now, a neuroanatomist
might be very strict
and say only those
things in striatum and
pallidum are basal
ganglia. But there is such
a tight relationship.
We're all going to
consider them together
as of the basal
ganglia. now interestingly
most of these nuclei
release GABA okay now
I don't know if you've
seen that before
that the connections
amongst different
circuitry major nuclei is
through GABA this
is a distinctive and
characteristic feature
of the basal ganglia two
of them are gonna
release dopamine and just
one releases glutamate.
Very interesting.
The striatum is comprised
of three nuclei,
the caudate nucleus,
the putamen, and the
nucleus accumbens. All
three of these are input
nuclei of the basal
ganglia. That means
for the cerebral cortex
to impact processing
of the basal ganglia, it
needs to do so through
these nuclei. Now
these nuclei influence
others within the basal
ganglion network by
releasing GABA, which
is an inhibitory
neurotransmitter. Very
interesting organization.
Now, let's point
to some of the
geometrical features
of these nuclei.
Caudate has a C
-shaped structure, as
it is going to be
following the lateral
walls of the lateral
ventricles. It
is the lateral walls,
so it will also
have a C-shaped
structure. The putamen
is going to be surrounded
by the caudate.
It's an egg-like
structure. And then there's
going to be gray
matter connections
between these two, the
caudate and putamen.
And that will be the
spaces between those
gray matter connections
are going to be
white matter passing
through that. And so when
you have this white
and gray matter in
alteration and seen in
cross-section, it looks
like a stripe and that
is why it's called
the striatum now
let's turn to the last
nuclei here the nucleus
accumbens which is
found um just underneath
the head of the
caudate and interior
to the potamen is
comprised of three
nuclei two for the globus
pallidus one is the
ventral pallidum. The
globus pallidus is
called so because it is
globe-shaped and pale,
and it is situated
between the putamen
and the thalamus. These
two are separated
from each other by the
white matter of the
internal capsule. And I
am now circling the
globus pallidus. This
portion right here is
the internal segment.
This portion right
here is the external
segment. The internal
segment will be projecting
axons to the thalamus.
It is a output
nucleus of the basal
ganglia. In contrast,
the globus pallidus
external segment is
neither an input
nucleus, like we would
have with the
putamen, nor an output
nucleus, like we
would have with GPI,
that would be globus
pallidus internal.
Instead, it is intrinsic.
It is neither input nor
output nucleus. nucleus.
The ventral palladium
is not being shown
on this figure, and
that's fine. It's
just giving you a
general orientation. Now,
it is an output
nucleus of the basal
ganglia, and it will
be closest to the
thalamus. Now, all of
these nuclei release
GABA, that is the
GPE, the GPI, and the
ventral pallidum all
release GABA. And all
the nuclei that we
mentioned before, or
striatum, they all
released GABA as well.
Now let's talk about
four closely related
nuclei that are not
strictly basal ganglia,
but for our purposes,
we'll put them together
in the same bag because
of their intimate
relationship. these
nuclei strictly speaking
are part of the
diencephalon and midbrain
there is the subthalamic
nucleus which is
lateral to that
hypothalamus and the
hypothalamus be forming
the walls for that third
ventricle that's for
some spatial reference
is going to be connected
to both parts of
the glovis pallidus is
going to receive input
from cerebral cortex
and it will release
glutamate that's the
first time that we've
seen glutamate being
released as the last
time we're going to be
seeing it released it
is exclusively the
subthalamic nuclei within
this collection that
will release glutamate
Now let's turn to
these midbrain nuclei.
There are two divisions
of substantia *****.
You may have not known
that before. What
people usually are
referring to when they
say substantia *****,
it is the portion
that would be releasing
dopamine. And so
this would be inferior
to this subthalamic
nucleus and this
is going to have a
modulatory function in
contrast there is a region
which is within the
substantia ***** as
a whole it is not
going to be containing
dopaminergic neurons
those dark neurons that
have melaton melanin
as a stage and the
creation of dopamine
this is an output
nucleus and releases
GABA okay so we're back
to GABA again lastly
we have the VTA the
ventral tegmental area
and that is going to
be analogous to the
dopamine releasing division
of substantia *****
it also does the
same and it is immediately
medial to it it.
So this slide
summarizes the
information presented
earlier about the
10 nuclei of the
basal ganglia.
We have the three main
divisions, striatum,
pallidum, and the
nuclei of the midbrain
diencephalon. We found
that they're going
to be nuclei that
are inputs. Those are
part of the striatum.
We have nuclei that are
outputs. Some of that
is going to be the
pallidum, some in the
midbrain and we have
nuclei there intrinsic
to the basal ganglia
that means that neither
inputs nor outputs
so that's going
to be found in the
pallidum and within the
midbrain diencephalon
the neurotransmitter
of choice is GABA so
seven of the ten nuclei
release GABA onto
their targets so it's
going to be one nuclei
inhibiting the other
and then that one
inhibiting an other
which which creates the
very distinct dynamics
of the basal ganglia.
There is just
one nucleus that
releases glutamate
and there are
two nuclei that
release dopamine.
Feature of life is
that there's a complex
relationship between
a goal and actions.
You might have a simple
goal, I want cheese.
But you're like, how
am I gonna get it?
Well, if you're a
mouse, let's say that
you're in a maze. So
you're going to have
to walk, you're going
to have to turn, you're
going to have to
turn this way, then
turn that way, walk
ahead. And that needs to
occur in a particular
sequence. And if
it doesn't occur in
that sequence, you can
get nothing or maybe
you can take a bath.
Okay. So the issue
is how to create that
sequence, that stable
relationship that will
achieve that goal, given
the possible actions.
and then you need
to put them in the
right order so for the
mouse to get the desired
cheese it will need
to execute the proper
sequence of action
walk forward turn right
walk forward turn
left and so on and we
can think of that as
promoting certain actions
and demoting others
amongst the total
repertoire of what the
mouse is capable of
and so this promotion
demotion and linking
of actions in chains
is what basal ganglia
does and sometimes an
important thing is to
just stop whatever it
is that you're doing
so for this mouse that
is trying to get his
cheese he better come
to a standstill if a
cat appears and be
as quiet as possible.
And we have this
capability too, that we're
in the middle of a
sequence. We can just
forcefully stop thanks
to the basal ganglia.
The next slides are
going to describe the
organization of the
basal ganglia according
to the Alvin de Long
model. These are two
individuals, Alvin and
DeLong, they proposed
it in 1990 and still
the go-to model today.
And that's really
quite amazing because
there's so many things
that were famous at that
time, like these kids
on the block and they're
no longer new and
they're no longer kids.
Feel free to ask your
parents about this.
So the Alvin-DeLong
model is going to posit
complementary pathways
for this promotion and
demotion of potential
actions that I described
previously vis-a-vis
the direct pathway
and indirect pathway
it does not account for
all the functions that
we ascribe to basal
ganglia but quite a
few the direct pathway
is going to describe
the flow of information
from the input nucleus
of the basal ganglia
to the output nucleus
and see that is a direct
pathway. There's no
intervening nuclei
between the input nuclei,
caudate and putamen,
which we remember are
parts of striatum,
and the output nuclei,
which include the SNR
and the GPI, the internal
segment of the globus
pallidus. This
connection is inhibitory.
You can see on the
upper right this coding
scheme where a blue and
a circle indicate GABA
is going to be released
at this synapse.
So the striatum is going
to inhibit this output
nucleus. And this
output nucleus itself
inhibits the thalamus.
And this is disinhibition.
So it will be
disinhibition of the
thalamus di because we
have two inhibition because
there's two inhibitions.
Now the thalamus
projects to the cerebral
cortex. The cerebral
cortex projects to
the striatum and both
of those connections
are glutamatergic, so
it'll be excitatory. So
we have an excitatory
portion and we have
an inhibitory portion.
The correct pathway
is going to promote
candidate actions by
disinhibition. So you're
going to be inhibiting
the inhibitor. So
normally the thalamus
is kept under inhibition
by the output nucleus
of the basal ganglia.
And they have high
firing rates of activity
in the thalamus. So
by inhibiting the
thalamus, we are making
sure that it does not
impact cerebral
cortex. And then we can
release the thalamus from
inhibition by inhibiting
the inhibitor so
the striatum will
provide more inhibition
under appropriate
conditions to the output
nuclei of the basal
ganglia and now these
neurons are less active
less inhibition
on the target
the indirect pathway
describes the flow of
information from the
input nucleus of the
basal ganglia to the
output nucleus indirectly
that means through
intervening nuclei so
the striatum will
project to the external
segment of the globus
pallis and the globus
pallidus then to
subthalamic nucleus and
subthalamic nucleus to
the output nucleus of the
basal ganglia and two
of these connections
are inhibitory we have
a series of inhibitory
connections we call
that disinhibition and
so that is going to
have some effects
ultimately on the thalamus
that will lead to the
demotion of candidate
actions the indirect
pathway is going to
demote candidate actions
because this chain of
effects will lead to
more inhibition on
thalamus. That will be
the ultimate effect of
the indirect pathway.
There will be more
inhibition on the thalamus,
hence the thalamus
will be providing less
excitatory input to
the cerebral cortex.
This is achieved
because we have from the
striatum to gpe that's
external segment of globus
pallidus to stn a
disinhibitory connection
and that means we're
going to be inhibiting
the inhibitor and the
stn is going to be
providing more
excitation to the output
nucleus of the basal
ganglia the output nucleus
of the basal ganglia
is inhibitory and that
means he'll be inhibiting
the thalamus more
This is somewhat
complex, admittedly, but
this is the arrangement
to demote candidate
actions or to put a
break on the activity
of the thalamus. We want
more inhibition onto
the thalamus, and this
is achieved through
the indirect pathway.
More inhibition, less
inhibition here,
more excitation, and
ultimately more inhibition
onto the thalamus. In
the example I gave
before of that mouse that
wanted to find some
cheese and walking
through the maze, there
were times where he
needed to stop all actions
altogether, turning
left, turning right,
who cares? Just stop
because of the presence
of a very scary cat.
Well, this blocking of
all candidate actions
is achieved through the
hyper direct pathway.
So there are projections
from cerebral
cortex to the subthalamic
nucleus, and this
is the hyperdirect
pathway because the
increased activity of the
subthalamic nucleus onto
the output nucleus
of the basal ganglia
is to inhibit thalamus.
So it will lead to
greater inhibition of
thalamus, and this is
the fastest way of
routing that information.
So they can sometimes
call that countermanding,
that you commanded
something and
then you said, no,
no, no, no, I'm going
to counter those already
initiated actions.
I'm just going to
stop in my tracks.
dopamine has a powerful
effect on basal
ganglia function
dopamine is released
by the substantia
***** pars compacta
to the striatum as
the input nucleus of
the basal ganglia
the striatal neurons
fall into two different
categories ones
which have a d1 receptor
the other ones a d2
receptor.
So neurons that have
the D1 receptor in their
membrane will bind
dopamine. And when it
binds dopamine, the
G-couple process will
result in a decreased
activity of that neuron.
Whereas for the neurons
that have D2 receptors
in their membrane,
when they bind
dopamine, they will have
a decreased activity
because of the cascading
process of the g
-coupled protein. So
you have this two
different ways that
neurons, striatal neurons,
can be affected by
dopamine. For one group,
the D1 neurons,
it's an increase in
activity. For the D2
neurons, it's a decrease
in activity. And those
two categories of
neurons have two
different targets. One is
going to be part of
the direct pathway,
whereas the other is the
indirect pathway. And
so you have increased
activity, increased
activation of the
direct and decreased
activation of the indirect.
And the net result
of that is the output
nucleus of the basal
ganglia is less
active. It is getting
less excitation and
more inhibition, which
means it will be
inhibiting thalamus less.
and that means that
thalamus will be able
to activate cerebral
cortex more so the
overall action uh effect
excuse me of dopamine
on the basal ganglia
is to inhibit
thalamus less and hence
you'll get more action
of thalamus on basal
on cerebral cortex
striatal neurons have
receptors which bind
dopamine and they have
acetylcholine and the
effect of acetylcholine
is effectively the
flip side of what we
have for the effect
of dopamine so for the
d1 neurons meaning the
striatal neurons that
have a d1 receptor
they will also have a
acetylcholine receptor
and when they bind
acetylcholine the
downstream effect of that is
less activity of that
neuron whereas neurons
that have the D2
receptor it has a
acetylcholine receptor
as well and the effect of
acetylcholine on that
neuron is to increase
its activity because
they're different
channel subtypes of these
acetylcholine receptors
and they're perfectly
kind of balanced.
The D1 goes one way
and the acetylcholine
goes the other and same
with the D2. So think
of the effect of
acetylcholine on this
network as effectively
the flip of what we
have with dopamine and
the net effect is that
there'll be more
inhibition on the thalamus
and that will mean
less activity of the
thalamus onto cerebral
cortex the loop of
information processing
from the cerebral cortex
to the basal ganglions
then to thalamus
and back to cerebral
cortex can be described
as channels where the
information that is
flowing through is
kept partitioned along
the way there will be
different sources for
the information in
cerebral cortex passing
on through the basal
ganglia and then the
thalamic targets will
be distinctive for these
four different channels
limbic prefrontal,
ocular motor, motor.
And we categorize
the last three as
nigrostriatal and the first
one here, this limbic,
as the mesolimbic.
As mentioned in the
earlier slide, there
are four channels that
relate how basal ganglia
impacts the processing
of cerebral cortex,
the motor, ocular
motor prefrontal and
limbic channels and by
that it's meant that
the areas of cerebral
cortex that will be
targeting the basal
ganglia there's many
different regions but
that information that
funnels on in is going
to be kept separate
along the way all the
way back to the cortical
receiving areas of
the thalamus that
receive their input
from basal ganglia hence
there are four different
channels so basal
ganglia is involved
in a wide variety of
functions because the
cerebral cortex is involved
in a wide variety of
functions but there
are separate channels
within basal ganglia
because we want to
keep those functions
relatively distinct so
the cortical receiving
areas are why the
different channels have
their name so motor
is going to be the
channel that will be
receiving information by
basal ganglia to
supplementary motor area
pre-motor and m1 whereas
is ocular motor. The
ultimate cortical
receiving area is going
to be frontal eye fields,
and then prefrontal
cortex for prefrontal,
and cingulate
gyrus and arbofrontal
for limbic, and so on.
So it makes sense,
this naming convention.
All these cortical
receiving areas are
in the frontal lobe.
That is the region
of the brain where
you do things. You
have thoughts, you
have actions, Okay,
whereas the
corticostriatal pathway is
going to be coming from
regions of the parietal
lobe. We also have
the temporal lobe.
We have posterior
parietal cortex, primary
somatosensory cortex,
so a wide variety
of areas funnel
information into the basal
ganglia. But the
output of basal ganglia
is to impact function
of the frontal lobe.
Now, what do you
need to know in this
incredibly complex
diagram? Well, you need to
know the things that
I highlighted. And
that should be
straightforward for the
cortical receiving
areas because it's just
perfectly linked to the
name of the channel.
So the striatal
nuclei, that's
a little bit
complex, I admit.
and the palatal
nuclei is pretty
straightforward because
it's all the same
except for the limbic
channel. The limb
channel is really
the outlier here in
terms of the striatal
nuclei, the palatal
nuclei, where it
gets its dopamine
from, and that is
why it is branched
off as the mesolimbic
pathway because
it is really quite
a distinct thing.
This figure duplicates
the last column that
we had in the previous
slide showing that
what are the ultimate
targets of the
cerebral cortex for
the various channels of
basal ganglia, and
that the motor channel
would be targeting,
not surprisingly, motor
areas. So premotor
cortex, SMA, primary
motor cortex, we have
the ocular motor channel
targeting the frontal
eye fields and
supplemental eye fields,
prefrontal channel,
targeting prefrontal
cortex and the limbic
channel would be
targeting the singlet
gyrus as well as
orbital frontal cortex
and so again the
targets of the
basal ganglia are
all the frontal lobe
different regions
of the frontal lobe
it should be noted
that the basal ganglia
also targets the
brain stem so superior
colliculus the mesocephalic
locomotor region
and other portions of
the reticular formation
are all targets of
the output nucleus of
the basal ganglia and
they will all be receiving
inhibition from that
output nucleus i
think it's important to
mention that the basal
ganglia is a ancient
set of networks that's
going to be found
within the earliest
vertebrates that we know
of like a lamprey which
is going to be dating
back a half a billion
years then we have
much later 130 million
years ago the first
mammals and then us we
basically start about 200
,000 years ago so between
this time of the
earliest mammals and us
live creatures like
the tyrannosaurus rex
and that means the
tyrannosaurus rex had a
basal ganglia pretty neat
there are many different
clinical manifestations
of damage to the
base of ganglia and
movement disorders is
one of them and that's
one of the most commonly
expressed so when
it comes to movement
disorders they can be
focal or generalized that
means it's going to
involve just a single
limb or am i involved
like the entire body
it could involve the
unilateral or bilateral
and if it was to be
unilateral unilateral
motor disorder that would
be due to the dysfunction
on the contralateral
basal ganglia
because basal ganglia
projects to the same side
thalamus, and the
thalamus projects to
the same side cerebral
cortex, and the
cerebral cortex is
involved in controlling
the contralateral
body, so the
dysfunction of the basal
ganglia is going to
be expressed on the
contralateral side.
Disordered motor action
from damage to the
basal ganglia can be
characterized as too much
or too little you can
have either behavior
that is slowed or even
absent or you could
have too much movement
in terms of numerous
involuntary actions that
you certainly didn't
intend so this would
be hypokinetic or
hyperkinetic and we
could trace that back to
damage to the different
pathways we could have
a lesion to the direct
pathway which would
ultimately lead to
under activation of the
cerebral cortex right
because the direct act
pathway is going to
promote action hence a
lesioning of that will
lead to under activity
of the cerebral cortex
on the other side we
can say a lesion to the
indirect pathway would
result in an overactive
cortex because the
indirect pathway
should be involved in
demoting um actions and
if it is um dysfunctional
then we would have as
a result actions that
should have been demoted
but are not being
that would be an
overactive cortex so
Parkinson's disease
impacts about 1% of the US
population over 65 and
the typical age of onset
of these symptoms is
between 40 and 70 years
now Parkinson's already
done some damage
to the nervous system
before that time is just
when does the symptoms
become severe enough
to the person goes to
the doctor and gets
a diagnosis now there's
generally no familial
tendency and there's
very few things that
we know about the external
causes of Parkinson's
disease so most often
it is idiopathic
meaning we just don't
know in this person's
life what was it that
resulted in them having
Parkinson's disease from
our perspective it's
just a battle of the
time and the progression
of this disease
insidious so it just can
continually robs from
the individual and
leading to disability
and death within about
10 to 30 years given
the current medications
and treatments we have
the defining pathology
of Parkinson's disease
is the death of the
dopamine containing
neurons of substantia
***** and the two images
on the bottom left
show individual that is
healthy at least insofar
as they do not have
Parkinson's disease,
dark areas that are quite
extensive indicating
the melanated cells
of substantia *****
and that's pretty
much absent for the
individual that is on
the on on the right with
brain of that individual
that was on the
right who was diagnosed
with parkinson's
disease very few cells
around here that are
dark now there are a
number of other brain
abnormalities that
occur with parkinson's
disease most notably
lewy bodies which are mif
-folded proteins that
under normal circumstances
have to do with
presynaptic release.
And these are mif
-folded proteins,
cytoplasmic inclusions
within a cell. And what
are the cells that
express that? Well,
cells within a certain
network of the brain
that gets more and more
and more distributed
as Parkinson's
progresses. So it's
initially not found
within the frontal lobes,
for example, but
eventually it will be and
it's correlated with
the progression of the
disease. But Lewy bodies
are not the defining
feature because you
can have Lewy bodies
in a number of disorders
that have Parkinson
-like symptoms but
are not Parkinson's.
There's a separate
lecture that will cover
this complexity so
there are a variety of
symptoms of parkinson's
disease the motor
symptoms are succinctly
described under trap
has an acronym for
tremor rigidity akinesia
bradykinesia and
postural instability and
you have these other
examples of hypotonic
motor cyst symptoms
like a face that is not
showing spontaneously a
expression of whatever
their emotional state
is and the voice is
extremely soft and
different individuals are
going to show different
degrees of these
various symptoms I
included a link here of a
young fellow that clearly
has a pretty advanced
Parkinson's disease
you can see what
that's like now the non
motor symptoms can be
very debilitating and
may even precede the
motor system so it's
something to be aware for
yourself and for your
loved ones and for
the patients that you
will eventually see that
loss of smell is in
fact the earliest
reliable indicators for
parkinson's disease but
there can be others
as well we have sleep
disturbances autonomic
disorders neuropsychiatric
disorders and this
would be reflecting
dysfunction of those
other channels of the
basal ganglia the limbic
channel and the the
premotor channel we
can understand parkin's
disease within the
albin de long model in
the following way there
would be a loss of
activity within the
direct pathway and a
overexpression of activity
in the indirect pathway.
And so those two factors
combined together
lead to greater
activity of this output
nucleus of the basal
ganglia that is receiving
less inhibition from
the direct pathway
and receiving more
excitation than normal
through the indirect
pathway. And so the output
nucleus is more active
than normal, and
that will be providing
more inhibition to
thalamus than normal,
leading to a diminution
of excitatory input
from thalamus to cortex.
Parkinson-like symptoms
can arise from a
variety of causes and so
you need to distinguish
is it truly Parkinson's
disease or is
there another issue at
hand? It could be head
trauma that occurs
with boxers. It could
be exposure to a chemical
agent that is seen
in an industrial setting
like manganese it
could be exposure
to a poorly designed
synthetic drug and that
is the mptp and so this
was accidentally created
as someone made a
synthetic ****** and
did it made a bad batch
and there are a lot
of young drug addicts
that showed up in a
frozen state in an
apparently advanced
parkinsonian state but it
was not parkinson's
disease per se because
it did not have the
typical etiology it just
had a very similar
end result and so a
diagnosis other than
idiopathic PD should be
suspected if the symptoms
are some metric and
if you lack arresting
Temer and if you are
not having the proper
response to dopamine
dopamine levodopa that
you introduce to an
individual the basal
ganglia is complexity
in terms of its
connectivity, the
neurotransmitters that
can modulate the circuitry
provide you a lot of
flexibility in how you
would treat somebody
that was suffering
from PD. The most common
way is to have the
person take levodopa.
And so this is a
precursor to dopamine.
so you say well i'm
going to make sure that
they synthesize more
dopamine another thing
that you can do is
try to make more
effective the already
existing dopamine by
subscribing a d2 receptor
agonist okay one could
also decrease the
acetylcholine
activity remember that
acetylcholine and dopamine
have roughly opposite
effects what can go
in and try to lesion
out a nucleus or at
least blunt its impact
on the circuitry
so there's too much
inhibition that's
coming from the indirect
pathway then partially
lesion let's just say
gpe we have virtual
lesions nowadays days,
where it's deep
brain stimulation.
And the basic principle
there is by adding
in a signal that's non
-informative, you break
the communication
between two elements
that would be in
communication. Just so if I
just say, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, while
you're trying to talk
to your friend, you
can't hear each other
between me doing that.
So that's basically
what's going on with
the deep brain stimulation
is that they're
providing a non
-informative signal that
blocks information
transmission and you could
change it up and say
oh i don't want to put
my needle here i want
to put my needle there
and that's why it's
a virtual region and
so last point is that
all these treatments
impact the symptoms not
the underlying cause
a patient suffering
from hemibalismis would
show fast ballistic
movements either of
their arm or their leg
or their both their arm
and leg on one side
of the body hence it
is hemi ballistic so
half fast okay and this
occurs with a lesion
to the subthalamic
nucleus on the opposite
side and that could be
understood as to remove
the clamping down
of motor action that
is really the role of
that hyper direct
pathway so when you have
greater activity of
that subthalamic nucleus
it will engage the
output nucleus of the
basal ganglia to inhibit
the thalamus so when
you remove that
you're taking away the
inhibition onto thalamus
hence you have the
ballistic movements so
this could result with
from a ******, and
it can be addressed
pharmacologically
to an extent.
Huntington's disease,
it's not a common
disorder, but it's one
that's talked about again
and again, because
we really do have a
good handle on what
causes it. It's the CAG
repeats for a particular
protein Huntington
and it's not that
it was discovered in
Huntington, New York.
That's just a coincidence
that you know that
that's with Long Island.
It's just the name of
the protein. So if the
individuals have a
certain number of repeats
they're going to be more
and more susceptible
to expressing this
dysfunction at earlier
earlier ages. And so
it's a awful disorder
that has motor
dysfunctions and mental
dysfunctions and the
overall behavior is that
you it's a hyperkinetic
disorder so you
show these dance light
movements and your mental
function is psychosis
because your thoughts
are kind of jumping
from here to here to
there as opposed to
something like apathy
and it is progressive
and and it's
terminal within uh 10
to 20 years of diagnosis
and there are some
ways of addressing
the motor symptoms
but not for um
addressing the
progressive of dementia
this disease has a
selective effect on
the striatum that
is the input nucleus
or nuclei of the basal
ganglia so this will
include all of them
but most especially the
caudate so for a person
that died without
this disorder we can
see their presence
of their caudate nucleus
and we can't find
any gray matter like
that in this individual
who suffered from
huntington's disease
but maybe a little
bit more visibly
apparent to you would
be the expansion and
dilation of the
ventricles the lateral
ventricles here because
of the death of the
neurons that would
form that wall as that
wall falls down the
fluid cavity expands
a constant concern is
prescribing a medication
to address one problem
and creating new
problems sometimes
these new problems could
be extra pyramidal
and so that's why you
have the warning label
on the medication.
An example of that would
be with D2 antagonists
to treat nausea and
unfortunately the
person shows PD-like
symptoms as a result
and so they would be
have rigidity like
somebody suffering from
PD but you know it's
not PD because they
showed it soon after
this medication and
they show it bilaterally
and so you can take
someone off this medication
and still these
symptoms will persist
for some time sometimes
permanently an
example of that the
permanent induction of
basal ganglia dysfunction
is tardive dyskinesia
So meaning it took
a while from the
exposure of the medication
for these the symptoms
or actually this damage
to become apparent.
So that's why it's
late. It's a late
onset for showing the
damage that was done.
A movement disorder
that's characterized by
them, you know,
smacking their lips and
rolling their tongues
and chewing. and this
stereotypical nature and
the fact that they could
voluntarily suppress
it if they focus
their thoughts and then
it will immediately
resume as they their
attention is deflected
really exemplifies that
automatic nature that
habit formation mechanisms
of basal ganglia
all right so that's
all the material that
we have for this
lecture let's uh give
a overall view of
what we've covered so
the basal ganglia is
a collection of nuclei
that are communicating
with cerebral
cortex disinhibition
is a prominent feature
of its internal
processing so nucleus a
inhibiting nucleus b
which inhibits nucleus
c the three primary
circuits in the albin
de long model are the
direct pathway indirect
pathway and hyper
direct pathway and some
aspects of basal
ganglia dysfunction
could be understood
within this framework
This is a lot of
difficult material.
I hope it was
presented clearly.
Feedback is appreciated.